so one of the things you'll do when
bring people on to your project is have
consultations you might have a designer
or an engineer come in to help you
understand what would be part of your
minimum viable product and what might
need to go in a version 2 or version 3
to do that we brought in James and Carl
now guys we have this app here this is a
prototype built out in envision and the
idea is that it's essentially a to-do
list or calendar app and I want to
understand sort of what we would go
about making first you know if we wanted
to make a version 0 of this so as you
can see we've got these these sort of
welcome screens this sort of home screen
and as we go on we've got a bunch of
extra features that I thought were
really cool we add it on you know we've
got you can view your tasks by the month
or by the week you can see an overview
of what tasks you've completed over time
you know what proportion of tasks you've
completed over time you can also see
Tess grouped up in certain ways so you
know all the tasks about cars or all the
all the recipes you've wanted to make
and then you've also got sort of a
profile in a timeline of things that
you've done and then sort of general
setting screens and a menu that make
sense mm-hmm sure so I'm really excited
about getting this built I first off
James as a designer what are your what
are the things that you would like to
focus on in in making this a better app
right now um color I would probably
change this color palette and then I
really like this overview screen like
this graphic is really cool but i'd
probably pull some colors from the
images like maybe you're from your title
bar and use the palette library for
android to make it kind of more
interesting and i really like this group
setting and like that's another place
where i might change up the colors i
might use more interesting typography to
make it more impactful of like how many
items i have in this automotive area of
books or whatever because that's not
that readable that makes sense and Carl
how does that sound you do think that
that would be a reasonable set of things
to start working on as rv1 well there's
a lot here in this envision prototype I
think that we should problem
we talked about some of the core
elements before progressing into
building absolutely every screen we want
to probably talk about just the the most
interesting interaction elements so for
instance I have to question whether or
not we really need high fidelity graphs
at this point right we're talking about
building a to-do app so let's focus on
the core elements of managing to do's
okay so so if I'm understanding you
correctly we want to at least have as
our first bit building out making it to
do checking off it to do things like
that yeah that's right and do you think
that it's it's worthwhile for us to
build out those those small features you
know this stuff is really cool and we
wanted to include that in the app in the
end ultimately we can make the app as
big and feature full and fancy as you
want the thing that we have to do those
express the core elements first the core
functionality what our users actually
doing with this app and in this case
they're managing their to do's they're
managing a little bit of their life so
we have to make that easy we have to
bring that to the forefront there's a
lot of extraneous views here that maybe
don't support that core workflow and so
let's I think it would be best for us to
focus on the core elements going forward
okay now James with what Carl just said
that we want to focus on the core
elements what would we be able to work
on what would be able to use your time
on to make these core elements a little
bit better you know right now that core
element if I'm understanding it right we
would want to have this this screen
where we have these two do's and be able
to check them off we would want sort of
our our screen of actually making to do
and then we'd want something like I
don't know a calendar or something to
tell manage their life okay so if we're
focusing on those three screens starting
with this general overview to do screen
I would focus on the transitions between
that screen and the creating to do just
to make it more instructive and make
more intuitive for the user for this
calendar probably a similar type thing
and just focus more in making it
glanceable and more easy to read for
or this is the to do I have this is what
i need to do at this moment or for this
day so even if we're just building a
small feature set there's still stuff
for you as I oh definitely okay so you
know we've been talking about this small
feature set and I'm not sure if this is
actually set that we I have the ability
to pay you guys for yet I have a
relatively small budget for this and I
want to make sure that we can get this
done within that budget I think we
should adopt a philosophy of launch and
iterate here that will give us the
agility to move where our users are
going with our software and allow us to
really focus on min viability first okay
see you know i think we probably have
enough to just to pay you guys to make
this initial Minimum Viable Product
really good really beautiful and
actually functional and then from there
we can use the rest of my budget as the
user is dictate I think that's a great
idea perfect so that's how a
consultation session might go you'll
have some concerns from my other side
and you'll have to balance them and at
the end you'll hopefully have a sense of
what is the minimum viable product
you'll be building as you go through
this you'll have multiple consultation
sessions at each release of the app and
it might be valuable for you to bring
these concerns in at every step of the
process